almost every manifestation of our
personality is artifice how we dress how
we do our hair how we speak you know
there is there is truth that is way
beyond where you were born and what
school you went to and you know whether
you smoked Marlboro cigarettes or
whether you're heterosexual or
homosexual I mean there's there's a
greater truth of the essence of who you
are and that's the actor's job to get to
and that can handle any accent or any
wig or you know I mean like it's
fascinating and it's opened up doors for
me later in life as I've started to
learn and understand what people would
call character acting you know and it's
it's opened up possibilities for me that
weren't there before but I made a lot of
mistakes turning down really good
projects in this kind of knee-jerk idea
that I had what was the truth
you know and I've come to believe that
that was a lot of and
self-preservation you know if there was
one thing that I've learned that I feel
whatever good fortune is has put me in
the position of realizing this is that
without risking looking like an absolute
fool you you cannot do anything original
unexpected anything that comes from your
heart you have to you have to shed the
that fear of judgment and that means you
may fall on your ass and one of the
wonderful things is that's our job as if
members of the artistic community your
job isn't to succeed
your job is to be one of many people
throwing your your the wind at the door
you're the wave 1 wave is gonna crash
through and it may be you or it may be
somebody else but there's a lot of waves
that are gonna add up to somebody
breaking through I mean do you think
people really look when Linkletter and I
first were going around trying to pitch
the idea of boyhood I got an idea
we're gonna make a little short film
about a little boy for 12 years we're
gonna cut it together be one movie it'll
be all about child it'll be amazing
so wait it's coming out in 13 years and
wait does a little boy sign a contract
you can't sign a contract for more than
seven years yeah but if the boys having
a good time yeah so I put my money in
now and if the boys having a good time I
get it back in 13 years
yeah nice what else do you have and born
to be blue and playing Chet Baker and I
had this idea that you know that he
would speak differently you know that he
he spoke at a higher octave than I do
and I wanted to do the whole part like
this and you know at first the director
looked at me like oh is he gonna
talk funny the whole it's gonna ruin the
movie but luckily the guy went with me
and yeah we could have fallen on our ass
but you have to try you have to try and
if you don't try you don't deserve to be
there you know you you I remember my mum
I've said this before summer but like
one of my favorite things that Allen
Ginsberg ever said was when I he went on
The Tonight Show like as a Hari Krishna
and stuff and somebody said you know
you're being mocked and he said you
think I don't know people are making fun
of me that's my job I'm a poet and some
middle-aged insurance salesman is lying
in bed tonight and he's thinking what
the hell was that guy doing on the
Johnny Carson show saying Hari Krishna
and it's it's breaking the walls of his
perception and that's my job as a poet
my job is not to be liked
I think Allen Ginsberg highest-paying
year was $17,000 right my job is not to
make money I have to you know there is
some balance at work you know I don't
want to starve to death but my job is to
be an artist and to do that a good
artist is ridiculed
you